foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening I'm Pez Morgan and censored
tonight is the Monaco facing his biggest
crisis I go toe-to-toe live with the
Taliban and boxing Legend Lennox Lewis
will also be here live but first it's
ladies night for my brain dump
America's kilometers overnight exit from
Afghanistan was a disgraceful disaster
that bruised presidents Biden's
reputation Forever on the world stage it
was a spineless surrender that made the
us at weak cowardly and chaotic there's
no exaggeration to say that it may have
emboldened Vladimir Putin to invade
Ukraine sensing that the world's number
one superpower may have lost his stomach
for a fight and most shamefully for a
president irregularly boasts about being
a women's rights Champion there's been
no greater victim in this travesty than
the millions of women of Afghanistan in
one Fell capitulating Swoop they were
catapulted back to the medieval dark
ages of Taliban rule these militant
misogynists have kicked girls out of
schools and banned women from most jobs
they've forbidden them from playing
sports they banned women from going to
public parks on the same day as men are
making long Journeys without male
chaperone it's been an Ever escalating
program of gender apartheid and many of
the truly courageous and inspiring women
who dare protest have been either locked
up or just disappeared
now it's other band has decided that all
women must wear a full head to toe burka
and their male relatives and employers
had been made the enforcers if women
show their faces their male Guardian
gets fined jailed or fired from his job
all this for me supposedly new and
inclusive Taliban which some people
physically branded Taliban 2.0
after seizing back power last summer
they vowed to treat women more fairly
they lied I don't ever want again to
hear President Biden boast about his
support for women's rights after the way
he betrayed Afghanistan's women but I do
want to hold the Taliban to account for
their treatment of women and I'll do
that tonight live when I speak directly
to their official spokesman
foreign
band froth of the mouth more than the
fact that for 70 years Britain's had a
female Monarch Queen Elizabeth deserved
for the Ultimate Nightmare a strong
independent well-educated woman more
than the equal of any man she ever meets
but these are worrying times for her
majesty now 96 in an increasingly poor
health her most important constitutional
duty is to open Parliament each year and
give the queen speech which formally
sets up what a government plans to do
but today she missed it for the first
time in 59 years and the side of her
eldest son Prince Charles reading the
Queen's speech for her as he picked an
occasional emotional glance in her crown
placed poignantly nearby was a massively
significant moment in British history
Her Majesty's government will play a
leading role in defending democracy and
freedom across the world
including continuing to support the
people of Ukraine
well to put all this into perspective
the last time an heir to the throne
delivered a state opening a parliament
Queen Victoria was still a toddler
but today was so much more than just a
constitutional collector's item no one
wants to talk about this but the
monarchy and with it Britain is now
hurtling towards a momentous transition
so much about what it is to be British
has been defined by the constant stoic
stately presence of one woman so much
about the queen has defined what it
means to be British we're going to have
to re-learn what that means and discover
whether the monarchy under Charles and
then his own eldest son William can even
survive let alone thrive
the Taliban models be thrilled that our
next two monarchs will be men but we
will all Miss This Magnificent woman
more than they could ever understand and
more than many of us may currently
realize
America's never had a female president
but according to President Biden's
sister Valerie the Cavalry May soon be
arriving unfortunately it's not the kind
of Cavalry that any of us want to see
coming over the hill it's our old friend
Meghan Markle
we embrace all women and we welcome her
to come in and join the Democratic party
so you think she'll make a good
potential candidate one day maybe for
president yes perhaps of course you will
what
is that a joke
perhaps there is somebody out there less
suited to becoming leader of the Free
World but I can't currently think of one
and before you think this is some kind
of joke remember that Meghan markle's
old friends probably thought the same
thing when she told him she's going to
hook her claws into a British Prince and
make herself stupendously rich and
famous I wouldn't put anything past this
scheming princess Pinocchio probably
sees the White House as a perfectly
feasible next rung on her Relentless
climb up the social ladder Megan's
already been exposed for inappropriately
phoning up bemused American politicians
to harangue them and I'm sure she's
looked at Donald Trump's success in 2016
and thought to herself TV style
zero political influence experience
craves money
deeply polarizing massive narcissist and
not currently talking to Piers Morgan
she also needs a new career let's face
it a current one as a professional
two-faced exploiter of Royal titles
isn't going so well a children's book
bombed a Spotify podcasts have barely
been heard Netflix just canceled her
animated series and the Queens banned
her in hypocrite Harry from The Bucky
and Palace balcony at the Platinum
Jubilee
[Music]
yeah Megan's doing the maths and already
planning the world's wokest inauguration
speech just don't say I didn't warn you
foreign
woman who wouldn't inspire me to open a
jar of cookies and I love cookies to one
who's genuinely inspired millions of
people in some of their very darkest
moments
Deborah hi I'm Deborah James also known
as Bell babe two and a half years ago at
the age of 35. I was diagnosed with
stage four bowel cancer it was at that
moment that my entire world changed and
they found a six and a half centimeter
tumor in my bowel Deborah James is an
extraordinary human being she's battle
stage four bowel cancer for five years
and during that time she's hosted a
podcast called you me and The Big C and
a column in the sun in which she
communicates about her struggle with
astonishing Candor Clarity and humility
she doesn't put any punches it's sharp
it's witty it's sometimes heartbreaking
commentary of the kind of things people
don't like to talk about what cancer
does to your body your children your
mental health today she reveal a typical
frankness that her body just can't cope
any longer she's under Hospice Care at
home with her family waiting for the end
of a remarkable life
the response to that heart-rending
announcement has been quite staggering
she just asked supporters to buy her a
glass of wine to see her out and in 24
hours she's raised more than 1.7 million
pounds for her bowel babe fund on a day
when inspirational women are in sharp
Focus there aren't many more deserving
of our respect and affection than
Deborah James and on behalf of everybody
she's helped normal life she's almost
certainly saved through her informative
educational homilies I simply want to
say this thank you Deborah
foreign
I'll be talking to the taliban's
official spokesman live we'll also be
debating the future of the monarchy and
Lennox Lewis will be here to tell me why
people should toughen up hallelujah oh
and the world's gone nuts Wordle
predictably has gone completely woke all
coming up and all uncensored don't miss
it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so there was a hugely symbolic day for
the British monarchies Prince Charles
stepped in for the queen of the state
opening of parliament the first time in
59 years that Her Majesty's missed the
event and gave Charles A Taste of his
future role as king
my lords and members of the House of
Commons
emerged his government's priority is to
grow and strengthen the economy
and help ease the cost of living for
families
well I'm joined now by the United
British historians for Anthony Selden
good morning evening to you sir Anthony
it was a remarkable morning wasn't it to
watch this moment which has never
happened in my lifetime to put it into a
historical context but to see Prince
Charles sitting in for his Queen and his
mother of course a mistake opening a
parliament was a big big moment for this
country
yeah it was a shock after 59 years
that's about your age peers and a bit uh
to see somebody else other than the
monarch who has been reading out the
Queen's speech uh Her speech but not
written by her to have somebody else
doing it was a significant moment but I
didn't think it was yet a historic
moment is there any chance at all do you
think that the queen might abdicate
before she dies naturally and passes the
Baton to her son because I've always
been told by those who are plugged into
the Royals that that would never be an
option that they would take
well she is 96.
and that's that's old by anybody's
standards and most people age 96 are not
doing a pretty full-time job and there
would be two reasons why that might
happen why she might abdicate or why
there might be a Regency as there had
been between 18 uh 11 and 1820 in
Britain where the Monarch then went mad
George III and handed over uh
effectively all power of the Monarch to
his son George IV he became the Monarch
in 1820 I mean you know that could
happen peers but it would need either
severe physical infirmity or uh her
losing her mental faculties I mean what
is very clear is that she ain't going to
give up she has no intention of doing
that she said uh very clearly at the
start of her Reign that she would Reign
to the very end and but for her losing
her capacity or physically something
going very wrong and her mother lived
till over a hundred let's remember uh
that's just not gonna happen the queen
has also reigned for over 70 years now
making the longest reigning British
monarch is she the greatest British
monarch
well the two-yeared compared to I I
guess would be Elizabeth the first uh
who reigned for uh well over 40 years
and Queen Victoria who reigned for some
60 between 1837 and 1901
and she I mean it was different wasn't
it because Elizabeth the first at the
Armada uh England had a different
position in the world the monarchy had
unrivaled power the monarchy uh ran the
government then as doesn't happen now so
it's difficult always over history to
make comparisons but I think she was
incomparably a greater figure than Queen
Victoria let's remember when Queen
Victoria's husband Albert died at the
beginning of the 1860s she went into
mourning for a long time look at the way
that the queen has responded uh with her
extraordinary commitment to her Duty I
mean she's very very sad deeply we feel
that we can see that losing Philip but
no sense of retreating into black and
into mourning and frankly self-pity as
Victoria did uh prolonging it for that
long so I think she's certainly a much
more effective uh Monarch than Victoria
although again that was a different age
I think she's up there you know she's up
there
with the greatest monarchs of all time
William the first Henry uh the fifth um
with ashinko Henry VII uh that he wasn't
very kind to his wives uh so yeah yeah
it appears I mean we we are still living
we are blessed to be living uh at the
time of one of the greatest monarchs
impossible which is certainly the
greatest in my lifetime because she's
the only one I've had in my lifetime and
that in itself is a remarkable fact Sir
Anthony great to talk to you thank you
very much indeed thank you
so is Prince Charles ready to be king or
is this the beginning potentially of the
end of the British Monarchy this is the
debate raging everywhere at the moment
joining me now to discuss the author and
journalist Tony Parsons political
activist case Kate Smith well welcome to
both of you thank you thank you okay let
me start with you we just had a
historian put it into perspective the
queen one of the all-time great monarchs
indisputably if you're ranking Monarch
she'd be right up there to me number one
but you know there's some other
compelling candidates you don't like the
concept of the monarchy right yeah it's
not nice I don't I don't dislike that
elderly lady that would be ridiculous um
but I just think it's 2022 and the time
for having a monarchy was a few
centuries back and I think if anything
has shown that it's the recent Caribbean
tour isn't it I mean how patronizing to
have the British royal family wandering
around the Caribbean expecting people to
Bow and scrape in front of them and I
think brilliant that people all across
the Caribbean kicked back and said hold
on a minute do you not understand the
history and what this represents and I
think that the history of what the
monarchy represents is no less of an
issue in this country where you know the
working classes the proletariat have
been continuously oppressed by this
structure of the class system and the
monarchy at the top of it and I think
it's about time that we all moved on and
interestingly you know here I am you're
asking my opinion about the monarchy
here's how the monarchy works we that
you know we are we are we are the
riffraff we are the bottom of the pile
we don't get an opinion if you want an
opinion on who should be Monarch then
you like me want a republican you're
getting an opinion right now Tony passes
that's my point Aid you identify as Riff
Raff
ugly Nobody Knows the working class
mentality of this country better than
you do you've written about it for
decades what do you think about that
there are young people there's no
unquestionably there are young people a
lot of them fueled by Meghan markle's
planes of racism and so on at the palace
and so on who have turned against the
idea of a monarchy
um I think the working class have always
seemed quite keen on uh the monarchy to
me when I was um a young punk in 1977
hanging out with the Sex Pistols it was
um the working class he wanted to give
us a little kicking the disrespecting
the queen
um I think that the um the queen with
her 70-year Reign has secured the
monarchy for the next hundred years or
so I don't think there's any I don't
think anybody alive in this country
today will live in a republic she's
secure she's made the case for the
monarchy and she's an exceptional woman
and circumstances were exceptional she
was so young when she when she came to
the throne she's lived such a long time
and I think that combination of stamina
and substance and I think she's got
better and I think she's got better with
age since um she's jumped out of the
helicopter before the 2012 London
Olympia I don't agree through to the um
the height of the pandemic the 75-year
anniversary it was amazing
I mean I know the argument they're not
elected people but I look at our elected
officials I look at Boris Johnson Kia
stalma squabbling over who may have
broken more lockdown rules who may have
betrayed the trust of the people more
and you look at the queen who for 70
years has held that trust has kept our
respect I'm not sure that that's always
been the case they've definitely been
times when I've been like really she's
meeting the leaders of Saudi Arabia has
she looked at the Amnesty International
reports on their human rights record
there are definitely times when I've
been like actually I'm not totally sure
that she's doing the right thing or
shaking hands with the right people but
the fact that there are elected
officials who are terrible and I'm in no
disagreement with you that there's no
shortage of those
um I don't think that the answer is well
let's just decide that democracy doesn't
work and throw out it's very ironic
actually to have seen Prince Charles
today saying This government Her
Majesty's government will uphold
democracy around the world and you're
like but you're the embodiment of us not
having in a way in a way it's only
passes their figureheads above
democratic system look they're not
elected but they do pay for themselves I
always make this argument to American
friends you say Well there must cost a
fortune well they do but they also get
it back from the huge tourism they
attract not least from the United States
the queen has been there for 14 prime
ministers sin and come and sin seen them
go and even prime ministers that won
three general elections like Thatcher or
Blair they seem like footnotes in that
70-year Reign and I think the fact that
she's she I mean I understand what
Kate's saying about shaking the hands
with um Saudi Arabians but one of the
great things about her is she's got this
ingenious for having the poker face that
she hasn't picked and choose the war you
know we don't fancy Europe human rights
record she's met the lot she's met all
of them yeah
I think most most British people would
would prefer a monarch that could meet
any Head of State in any dictator
rather than pick and choose about you
know because then that's where you you
get Megan Michael and Harry well you
know we can't meet Trump we won't and it
just seems pathetic it doesn't seem
Noble it doesn't seem virtual to me
refusing to me Trump seems pretty noble
but it does but it's the moment you
start picking and choosing which
difficult world leaders you're not going
to meet then you'll make much of the
world so you'd have Putin on this show
would you yes absolutely
wow but like but like but like wouldn't
you think hold on a minute he's
committing no I think hold on a minute
I'm going to ask you some tough
questions in fact
there's something more significant we
should do than ask him a question with a
pen don't you think we should actually
actually right now I'm about to
interview official spokesman for the
Taliban are you saying I shouldn't be
doing that well I'm not sure but I mean
sure if you're gonna absolutely nail
them if you're going to give them a
space to expound them their opinions
yeah stand back and I'll do it hell yeah
don't ask me twice I will do what I
always do which is I will ask the
questions I think people want to have
answers but I don't see any reason why I
wouldn't interview Vladimir Putin or why
I wouldn't interview my next guest which
is the official spoken for the Taliban
it's only final question is this country
read
for the queen passing because it's going
to be such an enormous moment I don't
know we're ever going to be ready
because I think she's an impossible act
to follow and I think that King Charles
III and King William the fourth will
never be and could never mean what she
means to the people because she goes
right right back to the second world war
she goes right back to that I mean you
said last night on this show
um you know there's never been a time
when she wasn't on the throne I'm 10
years older than you and there's never
been a time you're talking about 10
years younger by the way that's his
boxing training we've got Lennox Lewis
on there didn't that he'll be keen on
your training regime because you you
never get any older thank you for coming
on I appreciate it thank you very much
Tony great to see you again you'll enjoy
this next segment uh Tony it's a little
moment of dog dog love which I know
you'll love uh talk about heart stopping
this is the moment a woman's beloved pet
dog suddenly jumped or maybe fell out of
a window and it was captured by a
doorbell camera so we can see it Rachel
Green from Kent and the south of England
was on a doorstep talking to a Tradesman
when she's suddenly noticed an upstairs
window opened she only saw it because
the sunlight's reflection against the
wall caught her eye the next thing she
knew her beloved dog was hurtling
towards potential death see what
happened
oh my gosh get back
oh my God
Tony and I both Arsenal fans I mean I
like Aaron Ramsey a keeper but we could
do with Erin goal against Tottenham on
Thursday and from a dog that's lucky to
be alive to one that's actually saving
lives president zielinski is awarded a
mind-sniffing dog called hatred a medal
for services to Ukraine the dog has
helped find more than 200 devices during
the war has also become something of a
national hero and a symbol of canine
Ukrainian resistance what on Patron
we're all very proud of you
when it says that next I'll talk live to
taliban's postman Sue hail Shaheen
you don't want to miss that
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
it's been nearly eight months since the
Taliban we gain control of Afghanistan
or basically handed it back by President
Biden in that time women's rights had
been dragged back to the Dark Ages
Afghan girls have been banned from Full
education women unable to earn a living
and now for the first time in decades
all women are forced to wear the Islamic
face fell the full Burger in the Taliban
filling systems is a measure to ensure
dignity and safety for their sisters
well joining me now for the first time
since these restrictions are coming to
force is Taliban official spokesman
suhail Shaheen Mr Shane thank you for
joining me
thank you
you made a promise you rang into the BBC
on August the 15th 2021 and you said
this I want to remind you of what you
said
they should not be
their honor
their properties their right to
education work as a we have commitment
for that
so they should not have worries their
work and access to education will be I
think more in a better position than
they were in the past
so that was you talking about women in
Afghanistan and school girls and you
assured us that they would be in a
better position than they were in the
past but in fact they've now gone back
to the position they were in when the
Taliban was in charge before which is a
position of being oppressed why is that
and why did you lie about improving a
lot of women in Afghanistan
you're
first of all your judgment is based on
distorted reports of media
right now 123
000 female students and teachers and
government universities in private
universities
they are either working or receiving
education
do you know about that you don't know
let me respond to you
okay have you raised mentioned that in
your program about 4 million female
students in primary schools they are
going to school yes right now
all right
let me respond to you let me respond to
you please don't just keep talking right
it is true that some primary school
girls are still going to school it's
after they get to teenage years it's
it's after they get to teenage years you
have stopped them going to school you
don't want girls in Afghanistan to go
through full-time education that's not
improving the welfare and lifestyle of
women in Afghanistan is suppressing them
why don't you let secondary school age
girls go back to school
uh the secondary age School primary
school there are four billion girls are
going to school now the issue of
secondary schools education for girls
they are and can under consideration we
have never said they are banned
when you say the under consideration
what do you mean they're not currently
at school let them go back to school
just say you can all go back to school
that is why we are talking to work out a
mechanism and well I hope
there's nothing to talk about
a girl should be entitled to go to
school in Afghanistan the same way a boy
goes to you yourself said in August last
year that they had nothing to worry
about nothing to be scared about so
we've got nothing to worry about let
them go back to school give them the
education that they were having give
them the education that they deserve
just do it stop telling them you're
under consideration why did you got to
consider their right to education
I said the girls have the right to have
access to education as boys I am saying
right now that's why the the mechanism
in mechanism being worked out to provide
a conducive environment because it is
Islamic Society there is no question
about their right to go to school
again let me jump in that let me
response
and the female teachers there is no
problem about their right to an
education let them go back to school let
me turn if I may to the issue of the now
compulsory instruction for all women in
Afghanistan to wear a full burka if they
go outside in fact there's an
encouragement they don't leave their
home but if they do leave their home
they can only show their eyes and if
they get caught showing any more than
their eyes then the male Guardians
who've been appointed to basically
enforce this face going to prison this
is unbelievably oppressive way to treat
women in Afghanistan after two decades
of experiencing a much Freer Society why
are you doing this when again are your
own words you promised they had nothing
to worry about
the upright women
for centuries they have been observing
uh hijab
and they are our wearing hijab
voluntarily
so there is no addition boarding and
then and there there is the statement
doesn't say
is impose or the only type of hijab it
says there are different type
okay job which are acceptable all right
so this is important okay
and what you're saying is true so just
to be clear just to be clear every woman
in Afghanistan right now can go out and
does not have to wear the full burka and
she will get no bad treatment from
Taliban is that correct they're all free
not to wear the burger is that your
official position yeah
yeah yeah if they observe hijab it may
be a wheel it may be a piece of clothes
it may be a burka but it is the burka is
not the only type of hijab it is clearly
said any type of a piece of clothing
sheet covers herself her body that is
our hijab so it is not the burqa as you
said they do three the three that came
down from the vice and virtue Ministry
was that they were not allowed to reveal
more than their eyes so whichever way
you try and spin this that is a
Draconian measure which is designed to
suppress women more than they've been
used to in the last two decades you're
taking them back to what life was like
under Taliban before and I'm simply
putting it to you that when you took
over the country again last August you
made a lot of pronouncements the Taliban
that you were going to be a different
kind of Taliban a more inclusive Taliban
and that women had nothing again back to
your was nothing to be scared about they
honor their properties their right to
education work and so on the kids after
12 13 can't go to school all women have
to wear a covering apart from their eyes
you know they're not getting most jobs
now apart from women's specific uh jobs
which can't be filled by men they have
men now relatives and employers who are
exercising a control over them which can
be punishable if it's broken by
imprisonment this is incredibly
Draconian I can't think of anywhere else
in the world that is doing this to women
and I just ask you again what part of
any of this shows that you have changed
the Taliban that you're more inclusive
because I'm not seeing any evidence that
you're doing anything other than taking
women right back to where they were 25
years ago
what you are seeing have gotten from the
media reports which are not correct
their property are safe secure
there's no problem with that
about the the wheel it is not only in
Afghanistan all over the Islamic world
you may have it in UK the Muslim women
are wearing also in UK
about the only opening the eyes you
money are using the mask there is no
problem it is the same as a mosque
will be judged by their actions and the
reports from reporters in Afghanistan
are completely contrary to the picture
that you're trying to paint they are
talking about women who are now
protesting in the streets because
they're being ordered to completely
cover themselves apart from their eyes
they've been told that male relatives
and employers are now enforcing this on
behalf of the Taliban so either they're
all making it up and they've all gone
mad or the Taliban through people like
yourself as a spokesman are saying one
thing in public and a very different
thing is happening on the streets I want
to talk to you also about the economy in
Afghanistan which is a complete disaster
you now have millions and millions of
people living in abject poverty in what
way is the Taliban trying to improve the
lives of its people because it seems
from where I'm looking that ever since
the United States evacuated uh
Afghanistan things have got immeasurably
worse for the people why is that why
given a second chance at running the
country have you so far proven to be
such abject failures
first of all I would like to say uh 99
of the whom in they are observing hijab
voluntarily
so they consider it uh a dignity a
safeguard for a dear modesty modesty
secondly the poverty situation uh the
lack of job opportunity opportunity is
because of the sanctions imposed by
International Community uh following our
taking the capital Kabul
so they are punishing the people of
Afghanistan not the government by
imposing the sanction you can ask them
why they have done this why they are
doing this to the people of Afghanistan
so your position is that the Taliban has
no responsibility for the economic
collapse of the country and it's all
everybody yeah yeah yeah we have
responsibility what we have from our
Internal Revenue we are going that uh in
this we are spending that in the service
of our people uh we are starting uh
development projects we are paying the
salaries of the government employees who
are about 500 000 from the previous
government they are still working in the
government we are doing that but we have
do not have
okay financially so strong to store all
the development projects some of the
projects which were funded by some
countries they have been uh I think
1990. they have left it it's a shame the
truth is Afghanistan is in a terrible
state right now millions of people are
living in horrific poverty women are
feeling increasingly oppressed by the
Taliban regime and my message to you
simply my message to you simply is if we
take you at face value then we should
expect that tomorrow secondary age kids
can go back to school and get a proper
education and if as you say there is no
order for women to wear the full
covering and they can go out without
covering everything apart from their
eyes let's see that happen and let's
make sure that women that do Express
that right and that freedom do not then
get punished we're gonna leave it there
Mr Shaheen thank you very much for
joining me yes I I I I I'm saying right
now that the women in boys they have
right to have access to education that's
only by observing hijab yeah you don't
have any right to education if there's
no school our government has has not
said that that denied their life we've
talked about
this just for the record you have two
daughters do they go to school
are they are observing hijab they are
observing any hijab and so well that
means we have not denied
for our people
okay so your daughter's getting
education because wait a minute your
daughters your daughters get an
education because they do what you tell
them all right I'm glad we clarified
that uh so he'll show him thank you very
much indeed for joining me well joining
me now is uh fazia kufi she was one of
the first female politicians in
Afghanistan until she fed the country
last year when the Taliban took over you
were shaking your head in derision a lot
of the stuff that he was saying there
clearly a lot of that is propaganda we
know from the reporting on the ground
what is going on in relation to
education of young girls in relation to
women and what they have to wear what is
your response to that interview
well pears I only hope that there was a
debate that he could listen to and my
message to him would have been Mr
Shaheen you and I negotiated for the
past three years
we started from Moscow in February
um
2019. I remember as the first woman to
negotiate with you it was extremely
risky because I lost a lot of support in
my constituents by talking to you but we
did it for the sake of the country
because we wanted to come to a peace
deal remember there one of your uh
I know you're doing it but he's gone
well I just want to I mean so my point
really is how much of what he's saying
is just propaganda and nonsense from
what you understand on the ground I want
to remind them because I'm sure they
will they will listen to this that in
that meeting one of their negotiators
said that
from their perspective woman could go to
school could go to university could work
in business and politics could become
Minister Minister of Foreign Affairs up
to prime minister none of that's
happening I'm quoting up to prime
minister it was a room full of men
everybody looked at me and said well
miss goofy this is a big news but in
reality when they took over power on the
15th of August the first thing they did
in contradiction with Islamic principles
and what's happening in the rest of
Muslim World they stop girls from going
to school only girls up to grade 12 go
to school this is not happening in
anywhere in the world right anywhere
they stop women from going to work and
you know what these women actually were
the Breadwinners of their family they
lost their husbands in the war and they
were the supporters of their family they
were feeding their children with the
money that they were receiving through
their salary they cannot do it anymore
because they don't have a job to do it
now the last thing they did while the
country is at the age of starvation
economic crisis and people expect them
as people now in power to deliver the
last thing they did was another decree
asking women of Afghanistan to wear
their favorite hijab which is burka now
let's remember that women of Afghanistan
have always remained Muslim and their
hijab the same way that I do is
acceptable in Afghanistan by men is
respected and this is part of our
identity we don't need Taliban to come
and tell us that unless you don't wear
well which is burkha and it's even not
Islamic it's traditional you're a male
member of the family will be punished so
can you imagine in a country which
already the rule of law is does not
exist the main are influencing and
committing violence well that's the
right that's the great irony is that the
men are now being told to enforce these
rules by the Taliban and that in itself
is just utter misogyny great to talk to
you thank you very much for coming in
and just putting a woman's perspective
from Afghanistan there I think we all
know what is happening on the ground and
it's completely reprehensible the
Taliban are taking these women back to a
terrible time in Afghanistan's life and
they've got to stop it and the world
needs to be shining a light on this
thank you very much for coming in
on sense of next the one more
heavyweight champion of the world Lennox
Lewis will be here live He's fed up with
the world going all soft and he said to
tell me how we should all toughen up
look at him Mr matzo I'll ask him how he
felt being knocked out by me that's
Liberty Apprentice I'll take the smile
on his face
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
beautiful pictures
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
a boxing Legend Lennox Lewis won Olympic
gold before a master class in
professional ranks and became Britain's
only Undisputed heavyweight champion of
the world one of the best ever done a
pair of gloves but he's undefeated in
the boardroom
Dennis couldn't win without me as often
as he does anyone knew as much he knows
that I think he'd agree with that I
could probably
yes I do
I wouldn't have answered it that way
Linux I would have said absolutely who
the hell do you think you are I'd never
admit that he's a good asset to the team
I'm the main asset Lennox you're
fantastic but you're fired
terrible moment watching the World
Heavyweight Champion get me knocked out
by me
uh Lennox great to see you mate I did
the bruises still for you you still feel
those bruises of the big old Morgan KO
no I think uh I think I don't know what
happened I think he paid him some money
divisive guy on the planet
yeah he's uh incredible in fact just
before we came on air tonight the next
day uh Elon Musk who's just bought
Twitter said this
it was not correct to ban Donald Trump I
think that was that was a mistake the
pro events just fundamentally undermine
trust in Twitter as a a Town Square uh
where
um everyone can
voice their opinion so that was the
breaking news Lennox the uh Elon Musk
who's now got Twitter of course he's
he's bought it he wants Trump back on
Twitter do you think that's a good thing
well you know
um I think he thinks it's a good thing
so you know he's a pretty he's pretty
smart man
let's turn to why I wanted you on the
show lyrics I I've had a sneaking
feeling that Society has gone all week
in the last couple of decades that this
kind of new mentality of celebrating
victimhood people quitting left right
and center of being called heroes in the
sporting arena in real life none of it
feels right to me do you get that sense
as well and what do you think about it
you know there's definitely a a turn a
switch uh a difference of opinion and
you know people want to do it different
ways and uh you know they're getting an
opportunity to see too
but do you think Society should toughen
up do you think that we need to go back
to perhaps what it was like when you
were young when you you know you weren't
allowed to be self-pity you had to crack
on
yeah I I believe that you know right now
people
um even when it comes to fighting look
at when it comes to fighting people run
for weapons they should fist fight like
fight do it like the old times and then
as far as the boxing training nowadays A
lot of people stay at home go to Camp
you know isolate yourself Focus dedicate
what do you make of Tyson Fury I would
love to have seen you guys fight both at
your Peak who would you think would have
won
oh I refuse to answer easy questions
well mate you are talking to Daddy bloke
who's knocked you out apart from two
other guys that you wouldn't be so I'm
undefeated against you seriously would
you do you think you'd have beaten Tyson
Tyson Fury listen Tyson Fury is a great
Champion you know he moves well he's
Elusive and he punches hard got a great
job great uppercut now and uh all he has
to do is clean up the division like I
did and then beat the Next Generation
well you're slightly duck in the
question though it's come on if it was
you two in the ring who's gonna win at
your best at your feet you can put you
can't put two crank Fighters against
each other so you know that's not that's
that's naughty
I also want to ask you because you
knocked out the other Tyson Mike Tyson
and he just today got announced will not
face any charges after giving a
passenger on a plane a slap for annoying
him what did you make of that do you get
that kind of hassle
uh no you know I think he dealt with it
wrong obviously when you poke the beer
uh you know he's gonna he's gonna react
I would have just turned around and
slapped him and said
that's what he did wasn't it that's
exactly what he did you told me when we
did The Apprentice together you told me
that at the peak of Your World
Heavyweight Champion Powers you go into
nightclubs and the biggest guy would
come up to you and try it on and I said
to you well what would happen and he
went dude what do you think happened I
was the world heavyweight champion of
the world
yeah plus you know mentally mentally I I
play the whole thing in my head with of
course me winning of course of course
and one thing I would say we play 40 we
play 40 games of Chess during The
Apprentice filming and you beat me 39
times out of 40. I still remember the
one I won but you were very good
yeah people won't remember won't believe
that you actually counted every time we
played I did I did and I don't forget
the fact that every time you were about
to Checkmate me you stood up and walked
around the ball rubbing your hands in
Glee you were a very annoying person to
play chess with
thank you that's a compliment
it's always great to catch up with you
mate thanks for coming on the show thank
you stay uncensored I love you the way
you are and I'm sorry again for knocking
you out but sometimes you just meet a
Siberian guy in life that's just the way
it is okay good to talk to you don't
worry I'll get you next time
for the best champ
well it's the most tiresome and tedious
game on the internet just when you
thought he couldn't get any more
annoying Wordle has gone woke
[Music]
yes it's boring banana boastful and now
it's also censored the Wordle has gone
nuts and New York Times has admitted it
altered its Wordle solution for being
too politically charged they removed the
word fetus to avoid triggering anybody
over the Roe versus Wade abortion debate
I've got my own Wordle for that
crazy
yeah I think it's crazy to think that a
Daft puzzle game on the internet
published by a newspaper is triggering
and this policing of language and words
is becoming increasingly absurd it turns
out the New York Times has also removed
words like slave and wench and Lynch but
why would you remove them their words
actually exist yes they have meaning but
they weren't being used in any
celebratory sense just as words the New
York Times explained is taking some of
these words out because they're
insensitive or obscure and that wordles
should be distinct from the news agenda
really I think you obscure about any of
those words and nor should they be
insensitive to people when you take it
you bound words from Scrabble as well if
you start taking any word in normal
common usage that's potentially
offensive to somebody somewhere you'll
end up with no language at all and that
way Madness lies that's it for tonight
wherever you are Keep It Uncensored
goodbye
thank you
biggest issue in Britain right now
undoubtedly is cost of living it is
energy a rule that goes with that
inflation look you know I don't want the
government to do very much step back
from most of our Lives you know there's
a point when you say actually these guys
are getting a grip and that's somewhere
along the line you want
to believe that the system that is meant
to be running things the chancellor the
Prime Minister if we're going to somehow
step in and make life just a little
easier for the average person
this is talk TV news
good evening I'm Zora singleman Boris
Johnson's committed to tackle the cost
of living crisis in today's queen speech
but the treasury ruled out any emergency
budget it says Prince Charles stepped in
for the queen in a landmark moment as he
outlined the government's plans for the
year ahead
Elon Musk says he'd reversed Donald
Trump's Twitter ban if he completes his
takeover of the company musk called
Trump's ban a morally bad decision
and in day one of the so-called wagatha
Christie libel trial Rebecca vardy says
she did not leak any stories to the
Press vardy is suing fellow wag Colleen
Rooney after being publicly accused of
giving information to newspapers in 2019
but that's all for now we'll have more
after the talk
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign